[Music]
for anybody who would like to trade down
in the draft the major requirement is
finding someone who would be inclined to
trade up 10 of the last 11 quarterbacks
taken in round one were acquired by a
team that traded up to get them that
covers the last three drafts remember
carson wentz jared goff both acquired
when the eagles and rams respectively
traded up in 2016 the only guy who
wasn't acquired via a trade-up baker
mayfield who was first overall
last year it's very easy to point at the
teams chris to have multiple picks in
round one as teams that could try to
trade up but
anybody can try to trade up because
there are all sorts of things you can do
to get that ammunition to move and it
doesn't necessarily have to be
first-round picks that you give up to
move up in the draft who's the most
likely team in your assessment that
would try to make a move up on thursday
night well i mean let's break it down i
mean first off is right the quarterback
so who's in the market for quarterbacks
because those are the teams i look at
first ago who's gonna make a move there
okay yeah the new york giants there may
be a team that goes okay you know we'll
get to six to three to make sure we get
the quarterback we want i i find that
unlikely but i certainly think that we
can throw their names out there in that
discussion the cincinnati bengals at 11
would they get in the quarterback
conversation i do think this is a year
they're finally maybe contemplating at
least moving on from andy dalton or
realizing it's coming to an end there
okay you got the miami dolphins at 13.
the washington redskins at 15. i think
right there those are your prime
candidates for teams that if they were
to trade up or want quarterbacks these
are the teams that would trade up for
wanting a quarterback the list is short
right there so you have that aspect now
you get into the other aspect of the
trade mike like what we just talked
about a little bit quinn and williams ed
oliver you know nick bosa i think those
are the three guys that would be
worthy candidates for th where people in
the top 15 might go ooh this guy if i
can get this guy on my defense he can
change me around so now let's go to that
list there mike i mean to me that goes
down to maybe the buffalo bills would be
in that conversation you know with the
green bay packers okay maybe they want a
difference maker in their front seven
you talked about they have multiple
draft picks maybe that maybe they look
at it and go oh are we going to ed
oliver or quinn and williams or somehow
nick boses on the board at four maybe
they make a move something like that but
i think it's a very unique new
unique year sorry because of the
quarterback situation and nobody values
all any of those guys really as top two
or top three picks
and then the high-end talent maybe is
lacking in this draft a little bit as
compared to other drafts so uh that's
that's where i see it i don't know if
you guys think i missed anybody else
you'd certainly let me know and tell me
i'm wrong
no i i think that that makes a lot of
sense and it can go in a lot of
different directions you can see a lot
of different opportunities and and one
thing that is implicit in trading up
trading up from out of round one into
round one we've seen that happen over
and over again where teams will come up
back into round one after already using
a pick in the first round getting back
in and picking a quarterback late in the
process like the ravens did last year
when they got lamar jackson number 32.
remember there's value in being that
team that holds one of the low picks in
round one you get the guy for five years
it's better to get a guy at 30 31 32
than at the top of round two because you
control his rights for that fifth season
and the players for the most part don't
realize that they just think that it's
better to be a first-round pick than a
second-round pick not necessarily
if you're low enough in round one it's
better to go
top around two than bottom around once
so i would watch that too i think that's
where you're right that possibility for
that fifth quarterback comes in somebody
loving a guy and deciding we want to get
him bottom of round one and have him for
five years yeah i think i think that is
certainly the things to look out for
towards you know the end of the first
round you're right if daniel jones is
still on the board something like that
does somebody make a move whoever it may
be if one of the other quarterbacks fell
but again it is a unique unique year
without the top-tier top-shelf freaky
athletes okay there's a lot of good ones
in this but i really think i mentioned
the names that i think are you know
trade up into the top five and
specifically we're talking about the
jets at number three that list is short
for me it goes kyler murray ed oliver
quinn and williams nick bosa and it's
gonna be hopefully i think for the jets
in their best case scenario mike it
would be like okay
quinn and williams is on the board there
at number three
and a team gets scared that okay the
oakland raiders are gonna take quinn and
williams at number four so maybe the
buffalo bills decide to jump the raiders
at four and get to three those are the
possibilities i look at what if the
49ers take quinn and williams at two and
now nick bose is on the board at three
does that change the dynamic and now
another team goes oh wow i don't want to
leave him on the board for the oakland
raiders same type of thing but i think
that's where the jets come trade day
come draft night that's when it might
happen
and just because your trade up doesn't
mean it's guaranteed to work out last
year the saints went from 27 to 14. they
gave up the 27 pick last year and a
first round pick this year plus a fifth
round pick to get to marcus davenport
and so far davenport has not been nearly
as disruptive as
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports